[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
grandpa is pissed off losing his [ __ ]
mind
absolutely
melting down
Republican destruction
Republicans earned disarray and it's not
just the politicians folks it's the
Talking Heads it's the it's the
television stations it's all of them
they are [ __ ] upset that you went and
voted they are they are really [ __ ]
pissed off that women and gen Z went and
voted they do not want people to vote
this is ridiculous so much so that they
want to make sure to turn back the
voting age to 21.
look you dumb [ __ ] the reason
why gen Z got out and droves to vote
against you is exactly that you want to
take away their rights it's the same
reason women mounted such a huge voting
block against you because you [ __ ] boxes
just can't figure it out
people in this country don't want you to
take their [ __ ] rights away they
don't give two shits about gas prices
and milk prices if you're gonna take
their rights away
you stupid [ __ ] and I'm here
for it to be quite honest with you
I'm loving it I'm loving it
I want to talk about something else too
though because we're going to talk today
about the absolute absolute [ __ ]
meltdown
of Donald Trump
and I I don't know maybe this is the end
maybe this like the beginning of the end
because Republicans [ __ ] hate Trump
they they've hated him for a long time
folks
this is not new I mean I'm not talking
about the cult members right I'm not
talking about Maga I'm not talking about
[ __ ] Maga those are the cultists
they're in the Trump cult they're soon
to be in the Ron DeSantis cult
so it seems
I'm talking about Republicans
that they [ __ ] hate him they [ __ ]
hate that [ __ ] they've hated him
for a long [ __ ] time since 2015
when that [ __ ] came down the
escalator
they totally took
the entire country to make culture wars
out of [ __ ] children's genitalia and
CRT
and they put him at the helm of this
thing a guy who has never been who has
always tanked everything he's ever
touched everything Trump touches turns
to liquid [ __ ] and you're watching it in
real time
it's fantastic I want him to run today
he should announce right now please get
out in front of a [ __ ] microphone
Grandpa and announce you're running in
2024. do that
there would be nothing better for this
country at this point than if Donald
Trump runs for president I'm telling you
I'm telling you
he absolutely he absolutely
make sure that they say the quiet part
out loud
the quiet part out loud all the time
every time and as loud as you can
[ __ ] say it
the Charlie Kirks the bench appeals to
Matt Walsh's they're running around
trying to figure out why did Republicans
lose this election
look at the [ __ ] mirror you goddamn
piece of [ __ ] it's you [ __ ]
that lost this election you
[ __ ] are absolutely focused
focused on children's genitalia and what
bathrooms people are going in no one
gives a [ __ ] about that nobody
nobody nobody there was no one who went
to the polls I mean besides the cultist
right you gotta remember
when I'm talking about I'm carving out
the cultist
they're lost they're [ __ ] lost and
that's a group of people we may not get
back right I mean maybe little by little
by little by little but you're talking
about Decades of work
to undilute these son [ __ ] I mean
they believe JFK Jr and Michael
Jackson's still alive and they're going
to run the government in 2024.
you're not going to undo that kind of
stupid quickly
but Republicans hate this [ __ ]
he's going to destroy Herschel Walker
absolutely destroy him any chance
Herschel Walker has in a runoff which he
doesn't
is gone
it's gone it's [ __ ] gone
so think about that for a second the
reason why the Democrats hold the Senate
right now is because of Donald Trump's
mouth the reason why the Democrats will
continue to hold the Senate is because
of Donald Trump's mouth
oh my God
the other great [ __ ] thing that the
universe is lining up here
I don't know if you guys have been
paying attention to this but there's a
damn good chance whoever controls the
House of Representatives is going to
control it by one vote one [ __ ]
vote
wouldn't it just be I mean just the
cherry on top of the no red wave
if the universe delivers us a Lauren
bobert recount and she loses and that's
the reason why Nancy Pelosi is still the
Speaker of the House
I can't make this [ __ ] up you can't make
this [ __ ] up
this is story lines that only live in
this [ __ ] weird ass timeline that we
have
that's it right now in this timeline
this [ __ ] stupid ass [ __ ] that we're
going through
only right now does this kind of [ __ ]
exist
that's it
just imagine that imagine the universe
delivering us a situation
where we're waiting to see who the
speaker of the house is going to be
and it's because Lauren bobert loses her
election by less than 100 [ __ ] votes
imagine just just [ __ ] you can't even
write a better story you can't write it
any [ __ ] better than that about how
important it is to vote and there and
all the [ __ ] Mata cultists are
standing around going how'd they win
they won because they voted those sons
of [ __ ] they [ __ ] won because they
voted we should stop them from voting
this is it this is it this is the
[ __ ] beautiful [ __ ] picture the
beautiful framing up a wine democracy is
so important
why I've been yelling and screaming into
this microphone for months and months
and months for you to engage in it and
you did the entire country did
they [ __ ] engaged in democracy
this was supposed to be a 50 60 60 seat
bludgeoning
it would never was going to be that by
the way because they're [ __ ] boxes
but that's what it was supposed to be
they literally they're gonna hang on if
they keep the house they're gonna Hang
On by one seat you know what that means
right they're gonna do all these stupid
if they hold on to the house by one seat
just [ __ ] one
by the way
um
people voted for a dead Democrat over
Republican by the way I just want to
point that out that's one reason why the
seats are the way
whoosh Okay let's listen and then follow
me on this if Republicans do hold this
by one seat which it appears that that
we're gonna have either a republican
held house or a Democratic held house by
one seat here just one maybe two but one
very likely
they're gonna have committees and
they're gonna talk about Hunter Biden
every [ __ ] minute
every minute of every day they're going
to talk about Hunter Biden and how
they're going to impeach Joe Biden and
they're never ever
gonna be able to impeach him with an
only a one bullet of one vote and and
really honestly if Democrats only have
one vote they're not going to get much
done either
it's just not gonna happen all you got
to do is have two defectors
and that's it one Defector and that's it
you're not gonna you're not gonna be
able to bang up any kind of bills
we'll see we'll see what the
administration can actually do if they
only have one vote but wouldn't it just
be
the most beautiful thing in the world
if Republicans lose the house and Nancy
Pelosi is the Speaker of the House
I I make her speaker again [ __ ] it I
mean I know she probably wants to retire
and there's someone else that could
absolutely be the speaker but I I don't
know that that's what we do we really
got to own the magas here
we should just everything we do from now
on should be to own manga
I mean it's you know they do everything
to own the libs why not [ __ ] them well
I don't know if you've been watching
these Maga tears oh but it is oh man
they are delicious absolutely [ __ ]
delicious
delicious
how many [ __ ] how many [ __ ]
comments and threads on social media
have you had about red waves how many
DMS have you got
some stupid [ __ ] messaging him about a
red wave
[ __ ] delicious
but this is this was always going to be
the way it was there was never gonna be
another option here
it wasn't gonna go any other way and the
reason why is because they have no
[ __ ] policies they have no ideas they
yelled and screamed about gas prices and
inflation for months and months and
months and never did anything never
never even could get their stupid
[ __ ] Kevin McCarthy's little plan or
whatever the hell it was couldn't even
get that out into the [ __ ] Republican
media
even Charlie Kirk is upset that they
weren't making our was it Charlie Kirk
or was it Benny Johnson I don't remember
which one of these [ __ ] they're
super upset that people weren't making
social media videos about Kevin
McCarthy's shitty plan which it wasn't a
plan they were just like inflation bad
that's our plan yeah we we yeah we get
that I mean we know you hate inflation
we understand you guys been saying that
for [ __ ] months what are you gonna do
about it inflation bad that's what we're
gonna do inflate we're just gonna make
sure everybody knows inflation bad and
Joe Biden Joe Biden is the the hunter
Biden laptop in the uh
and Shannon in the uh
um borders that there's this this uh
we've got a a border and then um
Halloween candy fentanyl that's uh and
and um the gas the gas prices even
though they're going down they're the
gas price I mean it just it [ __ ]
didn't make any sense
it didn't make sense you know what made
sense you know what made sense to people
you're gonna take our [ __ ] rights
away from us what are you crazy
that made [ __ ] sense
it's gonna continue to make sense
to people
[ __ ] hate trumpism they [ __ ] hate
it even Republicans hate Trump
get it you dumb dense [ __ ] get
it through your thick [ __ ] skull
get it through your thick [ __ ] skulls
you can't be running around [ __ ]
taking away rights from Americans it's
not a thing you can do you can't even
[ __ ] suggest it
and they they're digging their heels in
because they never they're they'll never
figure this out right because it's all
about this Q Anon religion that they
have now this white Christian
nationalism this white supremacy that
they're [ __ ] hypnotized by
they can't even figure out that they're
running head first into the [ __ ] the
solution here
they're like why does everyone hate when
we suggest we should take away women's
rats to their bodily autonomy why does
everyone hate that
figure it out dummy it's a it's a really
unpopular idea
and they'll [ __ ] come vote against
you against it they're [ __ ] slam dunk
you every time even in a state like
Kentucky
what don't you get what don't in Kansas
what don't you [ __ ] get about it
I know you [ __ ] hate women but
look it's not gonna work this whole you
trying to [ __ ] bang up people's
rights is not gonna work and really
honestly this whole leaning in to them
raising the age of voting age to 21 I
hope they continue to do that nonsense
[ __ ] yeah let's do that let's make let's
make the 2023 elections the off-year
elections let's make them about that
let's do that and let's see how much
they piss off gen Z
they already pissed him off about Roe
[ __ ] piss him off about their voting
rights you stupid [ __ ]
good luck to you
democracy is going to [ __ ] come for
your dumb fascist ass
it will always come for you in this in
this country
the fabric of our democracy is strong
yeah it doesn't have a few tears here
and there do we need to make it a better
fabric absolutely
I think we have a long ways to go before
we would be satisfied with our democracy
with our nation with the diversity and
the quality here I think we got a long
ways to go
but it's clear this country is not
willing to let them take us there
they definitely are not going to let
manga take us there [ __ ] that [ __ ] or
their stupid [ __ ] ideas
trying to turn this into handmaid's tale
or some [ __ ]
the the age of the white male in cells
is damn near coming to an end
it's damn near coming to an end I [ __ ]
Elon Musk the king of the white male in
cells can't even figure out how to run
analytics on Twitter
and he botched this [ __ ] blue check
Twitter blue thing big time oh [ __ ] tank
this son of a [ __ ]
and he's the king of the incels and you
wonder why that shit's not working hmm
who could who could imagine who could
imagine why the these dumb [ __ ]
with these dumb [ __ ] ideas
can't get them off the ground hmm wonder
why that is
Wonder
because you don't think Twitter is some
sort of democracy of course it is
you get to vote on everything retweet
like
so much so that people pay for the [ __ ]
you have followers you don't think
that's some sort of democracy and Elon
Musk thought he would [ __ ] go in
there and just bang it up
nope not gonna happen
it's really stupid it's really dumb
stuff
this this [ __ ] white male fragile
ideology is just worn thin
on this country
and anyone who supports this stuff The
Thin Veil at his Q Anon or white white
Christian nationalism it's white
supremacy it's a bunch of [ __ ]
fragile white dudes who are scared that
they're gonna take a woman home from a
bar and they're gonna find a penis and
they might like it a lot that's what it
is they're [ __ ] terrified
terrified of this stuff
that's why they [ __ ] can't stop
thinking about it Matt Walsh is obsessed
with genitalia obsessed with it
so much so that they made it they tried
to make it their National narrative
genitalia was one of the [ __ ] things
that they were trying to make their
National narrative we fought back
against it here
and the way you fight back against it is
to [ __ ] give it Daylight
it's the best disinfectant of these
stupid ideas these dumb [ __ ]
ideas are the way to shut this [ __ ] down
it's obvious in Tennessee in Tennessee
over the summer they try to pass a
[ __ ] bill so they can marry children
these white fragile males because let's
be clear that's that's exactly who
wanted to marry these these children in
Tennessee that passes [ __ ] some sort
of
alternative Marriage Act
they wanted to marry children and Matt
Walsh is on radio talking about how
women get should be getting pregnant at
15 or 16. that's the most opportune time
because then they have to stay married
to their Suitor a rapist their entire
lives
and we exposed it and the voters saw it
and they went whoa that's [ __ ] weird
that's what that uh Republican guy is
running for office is saying here
we should probably not vote for that
[ __ ]
you responded you engaged and the voters
voted
the turnout was the highest [ __ ]
turnout in midterm history
and I hope this next presidential
election is the highest turnout of any
presidential election in history and the
next midterm breaks records again and we
keep going we keep pushing we keep
leaning into democracy because we can't
stop just because this election's over
doesn't mean we cannot look ahead
and yeah we're still counting they're
still trying to figure out who's going
to be in control of what legislator and
what house
I get it
but we did our job you did your job
and democracy
is alive and well
big time and the reason why you can tell
is because Trump the trumpetites Maga
the white supremacists they're all
losing their [ __ ] minds they're
crying
they need to cope but they're crying and
you know that democracy won that's how
you [ __ ] know
when the fascists are upset when the
fascists are on the Run democracy is
winning
that's the most important thing
and I know we didn't win some races that
we wanted Ohio Senate
um Texas Florida governor Georgia
governor
there's a few of them that we didn't get
some of these house races in New York
state it's all right that's all right
those those seats will be there for
another election because you did your
job you did your civic duty you made
sure to tell them in one National voice
[ __ ] off
that's the most important thing
you had your voice heard now they're
deaf
from democracy they have no clue they're
trying to figure out who to blame
they're like uh Mitch McConnell Kevin
McCartney Paul Ryan
Paul Riot they're blaming Paul Wright
they're blaming
they're blaming Paul Ryan this morning
Paul Ryan hadn't been an elective visual
in Forever really of anything Paul
Ryan's to blame it's for letting Fox
News he's on the board of Fox News it's
for letting Fox News disseminate their
stupid [ __ ] ideas and convincing
people this stupid [ __ ] that it was a
good narrative
and losing losing a big percentage of
the country wanting to even [ __ ] vote
for a Republican
[Music]
God damn oh they're blaming Paul Ryan
look there's only one [ __ ] to
blame only one there's only one
[ __ ] to blame
only one and he won't shut the [ __ ] up
this morning he is absolutely melting
down on true social and I know why it is
because they're all telling him they're
all telling him you're done you can't
run you can announce you cannot do this
if you run you will destroy Herschel
Walker in Georgia you will destroy
Herschel Walker in Georgia and they will
win the Senate and you will have another
loss
he can't stop losing they're trying as
hard as they can to get him to stop
losing but he won't he he's a one man
self-wrecking machine
and he's gonna do it he's gonna run and
he's gonna destroy Herschel Walker's
race Herschel Walker is gonna lose
and he's gonna get blamed because he's
gonna go there and he's gonna not stop
talking about it because he can't help
himself because he's such a [ __ ] man
child
good [ __ ] him [ __ ] em let him destroy
them
run [ __ ] run run you [ __ ]
[ __ ] get your punk ass [ __ ] out in
front of a [ __ ] microphone and say
you're running for president Cheeto dust
q and honor do it do it now
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
because you know you know with one
strong voice all these fragile white men
are gonna go yay
Red Wave in 2024
more
because you know if that motherfucker's
the nominee listen listen I'm even of
the feeling I know a lot of people want
him to go to prison like they want him
to get indicted and [ __ ] but something
deep down inside me
I mean just I I really don't want him to
be indicted so we can do this again who
the [ __ ] doesn't want to watch that
[ __ ] lose again
I couldn't think of one some [ __ ]
probably in this chat that could tell me
they want to they don't want to watch
him lose again
oh my God
this this country
is in good shape folks our democracy is
in good shape
and I know I know we've had our doubts I
know that we've it's been a long hard
two years after the big lie and the
Insurrection I know it's been it's been
a [ __ ] getting to this point but
we are at a point in this country where
they're standing around trying to figure
out how they [ __ ] up
and we all know we know we voted
and they still can't figure it out
which is even more proof and
just more reason why we should not put
them in charge of anything because they
can't even figure out where they went
wrong
in the moment five [ __ ] States five
[ __ ] States
either tried to take away abortion
rights or they codified it and every
single [ __ ] one every [ __ ] all
five of them voted
for women's bodily autonomy and women's
rights every [ __ ] one of them even in
deep red Kentucky and you can put six on
the board because of Kansas
earlier in the year
every [ __ ] one of them
and they can't figure out why how they
lost this election they can't figure it
out
good
let him let them be the ignorant ones
because folks their interest is not
democracy it's obvious when they when
they absolutely get trounced because gen
Z shows up and women show up to vote and
the first their first reaction is we
need to take away more rights
we need to make sure people have to be
21 to vote take away their right to vote
when that's their reaction we won
we won
and the good news is we will keep
winning because they keep saying this
stupid [ __ ]
we just have to keep pointing it out and
and giving it sunlight so everyone knows
who the [ __ ] these people are we cannot
we cannot let down
we cannot we have to keep leaning in
they are not just gonna crawl back
underneath their rocks right now it's
gonna take a little bit it's gonna be a
while
so we have to keep working every single
day every [ __ ] one of them and you
know I'm gonna work every single day
here on the Tony Michaels podcast noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific every
single weekday Monday through Friday on
YouTube Twitter and twitch simulcasting
from the Midas touch Facebook page you
can also watch it on our Facebook page
do me a huge favor go over if you're on
Facebook or have a Facebook page or if
you're on Facebook at all still go at
the Tony Michaels follow us there also
download every single episode every
single weekday on Apple Spotify Google
your favorite directory also leave a
review while you're there subscribing on
your favorite directory do that for us
too follow us on Twitter even though
it's a hellscape over there at Tony
Michaels pod it's Thursday and you can
vote for bonehead of the week
you know bonehead of the week tomorrow
on Friday as we do every Friday
we break down the bonehead of the week
you vote you decide who is the bonehead
of the week and me and my co-host Gabe
Sanchez break it down every single
Friday you can also vote on the YouTube
channel on the community tab don't
forget to subscribe to the YouTube
channel if you're here right now
subscribe if you're not on the YouTube
channel click the link somewhere or come
over just search the Tony Michaels
podcast you will find us on YouTube make
sure to subscribe you can vote for
bonehead of the week there as well
no double voting no I'm just kidding you
can double vote why not hell if you want
it
we're not we're not held to any kind of
election standard
I cheat to win right we're Democrats
liptuards
oh my God
oh
stay tuned because we're gonna watch a
lot of marketeers this morning a lot of
marketeers so if you enjoy marketeers
don't go anywhere plenty of marketeers
right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] them
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show we're gonna do
plenty of
surfing the [ __ ] list today the sweets
and the drink drink we're gonna show a
lot of bucketeers today boy they're
crying
oh my God you like the taste of
marketeers you're gonna love this show
so stay tuned for the [ __ ] list Roundup
because we aren't gambling going to show
plenty of marketeers today they're
melt down holy [ __ ] you are the best
audience in the entire world and I do
mean world because if you're in the
YouTube chat if you're not you should
hop over on YouTube and get in that chat
real quick
people watch all around the world every
single weekday for two full hours
every single weekday you are the best
audience in the world
in the world and we run on your support
I ask you I ask you if you could share
this link email it I know that maybe fax
it
fax it or or just simply share it with
anyone you have on Facebook Instagram
where wherever you like to chat with
people tick tock share this link with
them share the show with them that is
our the audience is growing by Leaps and
Bounds and really that is the best help
that you can give us also if you want to
go to Tony Michaels not live Tony
Michaels dot live you can give a
one-time tip or you can set it up
monthly if you want to support us we run
on your support we run on it here at the
Tony Michaels podcast that's how we
continue to do this show every single
weekday
for two full hours also you can go to
the the merch store here's a great one I
want to revive this one here
store.thetonymichaels.com get your
Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ] himself
everyone's gonna have to grab one of
these shirts since this son of a [ __ ]
is one since Florida's deep red
delusional
can't get their head out of maga's ass
so go grab your Rhonda Santos can go
[ __ ] himself t-shirt at store not the
Tony michaels.com that's
store.netoneymichaels.com also run over
there and grab your Liberty sweatshirts
as well it's getting cold it's getting
cold outside but more importantly
stay tuned that's how you can support us
this audience is growing every single
day more and more views more and more
live viewers more and more Chatters
whether it's on YouTube twitch Facebook
they're here you're chatting
and we we love having you here
we love even even the hate Watchers I
know you're out there listening hate
Watchers they're watching to see if I'll
say anything right well and go tweet
about it oh you might say something I
say [ __ ] all every day for like two full
hours
like every [ __ ] one of them two
hours a day
but I do want to ask the audience this
because I say every single weekday every
single one of them
but there's holidays out there like
Thanksgiving Christmas I'm thinking what
we do for Thanksgiving is we take off
Thursday and Friday
give myself and Gabe Sanchez a little
bit of reprieve but I'm I'm debating
whether we do like a best of and just
air it that day or we just don't have a
show at all I'm trying to figure that
out of what we're gonna do for
Thanksgiving I know a lot of you are
going to celebrate Thanksgiving those of
you that are in our country some people
in other countries they don't have
Thanksgiving it's an American thing but
that's why I want to ask should we do
like a best of thing where we air like a
two-hour show or something or you know
you guys message me
go go to Twitter tag me and you if you
can DM me DM me if I'm not following you
yet let's mention it I'll follow you so
you can DM me
tell the mods here in the chat the mods
are always monitoring the chat by the
way we're the best moderators in the
world they're always monitoring the chat
and moderating there in the chat
so tell them too you can tell them
they'll let me know
um what you guys think about some of
these holidays coming up rather we
should do a best of we should just take
off take a break for some of those let
me know I want the audience to respond
to this
boy do we have a lot of marketeers for
you today I mean it's just endless clips
that we could play I mean I could
actually just play for two full hours
without me talking which you know why
would we do that why would I do that
I love that's a that's a my most
favorite thing to do is talking to a
microphone
we could play two full hours just rack
it up one after another after another of
these [ __ ] megalodites these right
wing talkers these politicians
just crying absolutely crying
about their loss trying to figure out
why they lose how they lost why weren't
people interested in other people's
genitalia we can't figure it out why
people didn't believe this CRT stuff
why why in the world why in the world
won't they demonize marginalized
communities why in the world don't they
want to take away women's rats like they
can't figure it out like they're
literally saying that [ __ ] almost
verbatim
almost verbatim they're saying that [ __ ]
it's insanity
that they haven't figured it out they
always run face first into it
so we're gonna watch a lot of those
clips today
um and when Gabe Sanchez finally gets
here I don't know he's he's running a
little bit behind I guess
when fight Gabe Sanchez gets here I'm
gonna ask him about this Lauren bobert
race
this Lauren bobert race I'm just I don't
know
it just feels like that this this
storyline is going to deliver us
this absolute picture-perfect ending
where the Democrats and Nancy Pelosi
become the speaker because Lauren bobert
loses by less than 100 votes this thing
is likely going to go to a recount I
believe in Colorado if I'm not mistaken
um if it's if the race is less than a
half a percent
so anything less than half a percent I
believe it in Colorado it doesn't
automatic recount now I believe if if
it's within a percent or like 0.8 or
something like that she Lauren bobert
can request Gabe Sanchez is here Gabe
I'm talking about the Lauren bobert
um
I I from what I understand in Colorado
if it's under a half percent is it an
automatic recount is that is that that's
the automatic recount if it is less than
uh 0.5 or half a percent so we're likely
no matter the outcome rather yeah
whether she actually has more votes
because it's like within a hundred at
this point I think yeah it gets really
close like it keeps I mean it was like
60 it was 66 then it was 73 then it's
like 80 and I don't know where it sits
right now I'm like but literally every
every vote matters in this race every
[ __ ] last one of them because if she
does lose it's gonna be by less than 100
it looks like even with a recount so
when people say when you know when
people are like oh well my vote doesn't
matter it's not going to change things
it no there were there were multiple
races where it's come down to I mean
this is the closest I've seen But there
have been uh multiple races where it's
like within thousands right within
hundreds but then you know I think it's
157 743 to oh actually this is
this is a bigger Gap so we're oh we are
actually this might actually not be a
recount well because he he was supposed
there were still votes outlying that
they were counting in places where he
was doing a lot better than she was
right because right now in some of the
difference between the difference
between these two
our 157 743 and 157 357 and that means
Sanchez being Steve kernaki all this
boom I got my whiteboard we're going all
over the place but did you get your
khakis on do you get here I don't I
don't have my khakis on I'm sorry but
when I go out back and you smoke a Packy
with Steve kornacki that's
so the difference between the difference
in the count is right now is 386. so 157
7300
oh wait sorry wait so oh wait did it
change now it's it's switched
Lauren bobert it now has 157 743 votes
and Adam Frisch has 157 357 votes so
she's now ahead
she is now ahead by what looks to be
point one two percent
okay so so again but the universe is
literally going to deliver this I I
think this is what it's going to be the
universe is going to deliver us this
storyline where this race determines
who is control of the house it looks
like it could do that because we still
have some outlying accounts still
happening and I believe as long as the
Democrat outside this Boba race as long
as Democrats win the races that they're
kind of ahead in and the Republicans win
the races that they're ahead in that
it's gonna we're literally gonna have a
House of Representatives whether it's
Republican or Democrat with one vote
just one vote of dirty it's gonna be
like
and there's no way and and the other
well the the other thing I want to bring
up here is like this Lauren bobert has
been [ __ ] silent until this morning
right when the numbers flipped and she
was like you know she was like oh what's
going on you know what's what's the deal
was it taking so long stop to count now
when I'm winning right but she in the
last in the last 36 hours she was
completely silent from the moment it
switched over and it was him in the
league what's the percentage that they
still have outlining is it one two
percent of the vote laughter
um because I think it was 95 earlier so
they must have had a ballot about this
says 95 of votes in that's just from New
York Times but I'm sure if I looked up
uh
uh if I go just search Lauren bobert and
then I'll give me the AP this is 98
percent
reporting it's still the same amount so
it's still uh I mean there's gonna be
there's gonna be a recount right
automatically because right now well and
even if there's not a recap I I believe
no matter who wins that race who they
call it for
um the opponent is gonna call for a
recount oh yeah even if the RNC or DNC
goes in and pays for the recount they're
definitely gonna pay for that I mean
look because this seat this seat May
determine who actually holds the house I
mean it may one 100 I mean even if you
look at where the remaining counties are
you've got
uh uh there are still
well see there's an 80 County
uh Pitkin County 80 reporting he's up 58
on that one uh most of them are 95
Garfield is another one that's only
reporting 90 and he's up 14 on that one
so these
you know there are more more counties
that are reporting with Frisch that have
less than 90 so there's two that are
less than 95 percent most of them are
greater than or equal to 95 percent
reporting right now but there's also
again a fair amount that are larger
chunks that are pro
fresh than Boba right now so you heard
it right here on the Tony Michaels
podcast from Gabe kernaki
um he's giving us the election results
in real time you know I think that is
the craziest part about this whole thing
is that here we are on Thursday we as we
as a nation can still not figure out how
to make sure we get these states to
where they can count faster
um States like Florida and I know
they're red but but after the 2000 uh
presidential election Florida did a lot
of a lot of soul searching on how they
actually tabulated elections and how
fast because of the problems that they
had with the Chads
um and and they actually believe it or
not
to give Florida as a whole credit as
their state election apparatus even
though they bang it up and Ron DeSantis
tries to bang it up and Republicans
really do a great job of suppressing
votes down there their ability to count
votes is outstanding I mean you get
Florida results almost immediately which
is part of the red Mirage now right
because right that's what happened on
Tuesday night is the Florida results
dropped and everyone's like yeah
everything's gonna go red and then that
was the only thing that went red right
and not only that but you've also got
Florida's on the East Coast so it's
going to be one of the first states to
report so you've got a way so it's going
to be the first to revoke because it's
on the east coast and it's going to be
the first to report because they're so
fast accounting right because they made
sure of that after the two I mean it's
been 22 years since that election so
they've done a lot of things to make
sure that that [ __ ] in 2000 never
happens to Florida ever again which some
good some bad right yeah like but no I
mean you know it's not just that but
also like the redistricting that they
you know obviously people what's gonna I
mean we're hearing things right now from
Republicans that are like oh the voting
age should be 21 which if anyone doesn't
know this the voting age was changed in
1971 it was signed into law by Richard
Nixon okay it was changing the date 26th
amendment 26th amendment it changed the
voting age from 21 to 18. a lot of this
was due to the fact that there were you
know soldiers who were you know the
whole thing was like old enough to old
enough to to fight or good enough to go
to war old enough to vote right and that
was a big that was a big push that they
had uh at the time in addition to the it
was an uh an amendment to the 1965
um
civil rights and so that was something
that was added on uh they're talking
about taking it away from the good luck
Amendment again good luck Republicans
want to repeal which again would go into
this whole thing about saying oh well if
you take away that then you know there's
it's it's
because where are they going to take
this away where exactly I mean with with
even if Lauren bobert wins here and
she's the one vote they have in in the
house
Trump is going to dump all over [ __ ]
Herschel Walker and destroy that race so
they're not going to happen who's going
to repeal who is going to change the
voting age this is really stupid why
would they even trying to even have this
discussion like it doesn't make any
sense but that is the point right the
cruelty the cruelty and the fascism is
the point like that's yeah I mean they
don't want they do I think there's
actually there's a girl in California
there's a city out here in California
who she's actually pushing to get the
voting age to 16 right which I'm like
dude if my logic and I just want to put
this out there make it a bumper sticker
t-shirt whatever maybe we should make it
but I think it's old enough to have a
baby old enough to vote because if
Republicans really want to push this
whole thing to say like because at the
time there were a ton of Republicans who
said well they're not mature enough and
they're not developed enough you know to
actually vote which was the whole
argument of like well if you're gonna
send them off to war and let them kill
people right if they're [ __ ] old
enough to kill [ __ ] in war for
their country they should be able to
vote for the politician that sends them
there so so I look at this and I say if
you're telling me that a 12 year old
girl has the mental emotional physical
capacity to have a child a child having
a child if you think that's okay right
but you don't think it's okay for them
to have the mental capacity or emotional
status or or or
maturity to get an abortion
then I would say that those people those
children have the ability to vote if
you're going to say that they have the
ability and they're old enough to have a
baby then [ __ ] it why wouldn't we give
them the right to vote but here's the
same thing here's the thing though
jinzi gets out and votes against them
and almost immediately and and the
reason why gen Z went out and voted
against him is immediately what their
response to it take away their right to
vote like that's the exact reason why
they've went and voted against you they
didn't vote for Democrats that that's
the other [ __ ] thing that I want
everyone to understand gen Z women did
not vote for Democrats they voted
against fascism you see it in Kentucky
for crying out loud red Kentucky that
re-elected Rand Paul they told them to
[ __ ] off when they wanted to take away
their bodily autonomy Kansas the same
[ __ ] way these people are just
deluded to think that they absolutely
can run on taking away people's rights
and I have fake Gabe in here earlier let
me see if I can find it I saw him he was
like who's saying that I can tell you
right now an example of some of of
someone who is saying you can literally
go to Twitter and search this you can
just voting 21 one of the main people
right now that I saw yesterday is
pushing it is Bridget Gabriel okay
Bridget Gabriel act Bridget or whatever
her handle is she's very much a Trumper
loves Trump couldn't get enough of that
Trump
she yeah
yeah right it's just a small little
mushroom right she's someone an example
that literally you can watch it in real
time as the votes come in and you see
the demographics and you see the Red
Wave turned down to a trickle down to a
little you know little little peck of a
blood splatter that is someone you watch
in like four tweets she goes from
Red Wave to what the [ __ ] going on to
this must be uh this must be fraud or
this is suppression too we should not
let people who are 20 or we should make
sure that the voting age is 21. okay
well here's the thing too if they're
going to it and search for it if they're
going to go after the Gen Z vote what
what's going to stop them from starting
the narrative to go after women's vote
right I said this months ago yeah I said
this months ago you start this you start
this road down this [ __ ] fascism just
for fake highway I put it in the chat
that's just one one of several many well
we're going to look at here let's let's
do this let's go to the [ __ ] let's round
up let's round up all the Tweety tweets
and journey Trends why Twitter still
exist here now let's start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the show
you've reached the part of the show
where we round up all the Tweety tweets
and training Trends while they still
exist
now this Elon news holy moly why we're
talking about Twitter here uh as I go to
these oh my God so the uh the rollout of
not only the art that we showed
yesterday but the actual roll out of the
um you know the Technic technical stuff
of the new verified Twitter didn't go
well at all no it it should I mean I it
shipped the bed worse than the Red Wave
really I you know I really did I mean
it's I will say this as someone as
someone from the tech side uh it's very
concerning because here's the thing
you've got Bad actors and the whole
point of Elon to do this was like we
want to reduce scam we want to reduce
Bots we want to reduce people who are
like Bad actors maliciously on on the
network right right it created them it
literally exacerbated the problem and
created a ton of scams listen oh wait a
second this guy is super smart nope this
guy is super smart he invented electric
cars he invented Rockets
this is the smartest man alive he
invented he invented digital currency he
minted all kinds of things he is the
smartest man and that's why he's the
richest man this uh link you sent me
from Bridget Gabriel yeah look at this
just for fake game this is just for fake
look at this oh
what it says this tweet is unavailable
oh did she block you I have I have known
he she might have blocked me I I she
minded blocked me let me yeah I think
she blocked you did she really I don't
know I can see it right oh man let me
let me go because I I said something to
this tweet
um so let me go find it here I actually
responded to this
and so that may be the reason why she um
blocked me here
um what a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know these
these goddamn megalodites are so weak
YouTube I'm gonna point out one thing
and they get all pissed off I mean what
what am I supposed to do right well also
it's like for a group like literally the
for a group that calls other people
snowflakes you would think that
Republicans would know how to stop
crying and just take the [ __ ] L okay
no they no no way you would think you
would think the the you're you're a
snowflake get over it libtard all this
stuff just like move on stop crying
tears yeah awesome the cope but then as
soon as they get in a position where
they're the victim when you really block
me because I'm here I'm on the uh I'm on
the Pod account okay she [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey hey Bridget Gabriel you are such a
little manga snowflake you [ __ ]
snowflake I gotta go find what she did
yeah what what I said but here's the um
here's the raising the voting age to 21.
here it is
and she's got a blue check and this blue
check is not because she paid for it
right I mean she may be paying for it
but she had this blue checkbook but she
is you know you've got a little Laura
Ingraham was on went on a fox and she
was like oh man we got to figure out
this young demo these young voters
what's going on you got Ted Cruz that's
basically like [ __ ] them kids all of
these people in the Republican Party are
not happy that young voters went out and
voted against them because they saw the
Republican Party voting against their
own self-interest hey we wanted to we
don't support uh tuition uh loan
um
uh cancellation we we don't support
um Universal Health Care we don't uh
believe that we should actually fix this
gun problem we should put more guns in
schools like I saw a tweet from someone
and said it's almost like the younger
generation had been living through years
of active shooter drills and there's and
something else where they realized that
it was enough right and that's really
what it is
kids now who are 18 [ __ ] outraged
active engaged those kids right now are
the ones who are pushing to
to actually make sure that we have a
better country a better life a better
world of opportunity in the United
States what we're all promised right
by the way
[Music]
I really gave it to her heart I honestly
honestly this is It's a pretty tame this
is this is a tame Tony right like yeah
he's like I come pretty [ __ ] hard at
people right I don't give a [ __ ] right I
really don't give up so this is there's
no swear words there's nothing I didn't
even say the word [ __ ] right you kidding
me Bridget Gabriel I would I was
actually wondering what I said in my
Jesus I must have really handed it to
her this is what I he doesn't like yeah
I quote tweeted her gen Z understood the
assignment
that's what I quote that's like holy
[ __ ] are you kidding me that's right
here's the thing they're they're looking
at Generation Z right gen Z as the enemy
they don't identify like hey maybe
there's Republican voters who are in gen
Z which of course there are yeah of
course there are because I I believe the
numbers are showing that it's about 70
of gen Z voted against Republicans right
and I say that that way because I I
there's a lot of gen Z that probably
didn't really like the Democratic
candidates but they were like it's more
important to actually vote against
Republicans gen Z understood that
assignment and that's right that's what
I was trying to say to her she's really
upset about it apparently she [ __ ]
blocks gen Z looked at what was going on
and they realized if we don't do
anything about this right now the people
that are going to go into office and
push the policies that they've been
promoting which is fascist they want to
take away your rights they want to take
a boy a bottle of autonomy they want to
take everything away that we once had
right uh they want to repeal amendments
they want to take this and they want to
take that
they're the youngest group of people in
this country and they literally saw what
was happening they said we do not want
to live our adult life under this type
of world we don't want to have this
control that other people have over our
own body we don't want to live in this
world where other people are trying to
suppress our Vote or oppress our our
existence in this world and they saw
that and they said dude we're not good
we we are we are the ones who have to
live through the most of this the older
Generations who are out of the way out
Boomers and everyone else you guys are
kind of out you don't really need to do
this and as we'll notice in the next
four like the next election in four
years six years eight years you'll
you'll see that this group is only
getting [ __ ] bigger she must be
listening because she didn't block me
how can I see that tweet on that account
you know what she probably reported it
that's probably what she did
um
that's weird isn't it that's [ __ ]
weird I don't know she didn't block me
so I gotta you know I want facts to be
facts I don't want fake to you know
claim on that for a fact she didn't
block me I'm not sure what the hell is
going on I don't know but maybe maybe
you should go ask maybe you should go
ask
um did she report that tweet she
probably did she probably reported the
Tweet
um because I said they understood the
assignment because what she said in the
Tweet is that Generation Z is destroy
listen it's destroying the country at
The Ballot Box right you are so [ __ ]
dumb these people really do not have any
clue what country they live in they have
no idea how in the [ __ ] don't they know
how but also it's like work right
exactly and it's like all right The
Ballot Box are we we're talking just
like the drop-off ballots like you're
saying that these people aren't voting
in person
easy because you're gonna confuse him
here you're gonna really confuse
somebody and I just want to know how
they're destroying not the people that
are literally that that were standing in
Arizona with flak jackets guns face
masks body cams you're going to tell me
that those people who are committing
voter intimidation and had to have a
restraining order which is insane that
we even needed a judge to say that was
[ __ ] intimidation but you're gonna
tell me that those people who are
actively intimidating voters standing
out yelling asking questions showing
their guns trying to to get them to turn
away and go somewhere else because they
don't like the way they look or they
assume that because their appearance
they're going to vote a certain way so
they could suppress the vote you're
going to tell me that that is not
ruining or destroying the voter box
get the [ __ ] out of here well I mean
yelling mule at them because of a
fraudulent uh movie the people who made
the movie and wrote the book are well uh
made the movie a book that was that was
taken off the bookshelves by the
Publishers
they're in jail right now for contempt
because they won't actually give their
Source because they don't actually have
one they made that [ __ ] up speaking of
making [ __ ] up and crybaby
um magas Trump is losing his [ __ ]
mind over on true social this is a video
it's a screen video that Aaron Rupert
make made um I want to point something
out in this video if everyone will watch
this but and I'm not going to read all
this [ __ ] chucklehead statements
because they're just they're unhinged
and based in no reality honestly this is
what this feels like
like his absolute meltdown on true
social it really feels like the Cheeto
does q and honor actually has now
believed that he can type in anything
and these people will believe it like
every we've been saying it for a long
time that they'll believe anything he
says that the media has been saying it
for a long time so I think now Donald
Trump has believed himself that oh yeah
can say anything he can type in anything
and half the country believes it like I
mean it literally he literally is
deluded and delusional to a point where
he believes half the country loves him
and he just types in something even
though it's a lie they'll believe it
which is [ __ ] Insanity I mean if if
you say something enough times right
again like these are tactics that were
used by literal Nazis Hitler would would
talk about how the news couldn't be
trusted he would say oh they're they're
aligned they're fake they can't be
trusted this is this is absurd this and
that and trying to make sure that there
was no Free Press so in in opposition
whenever he spoke he was the one who was
talking to be true like he was the one
who was speaking truth he was the one
that was spreading these lies and
calling them as truths I mean even okay
I just want to that
this is hilarious this is the best part
about this video literally this is an
embedded ad okay on true social now
here's Gabe you're I know you're gonna
tear this apart um and tell me if I'm
right here so this is posted by true
social this is not posted by a company
this is not like an ad buy from another
a corporation
this is
see like I don't know how they've got on
the back end in terms of who's I mean
obviously so this is this is right here
this is posted by truth social right so
typically if there was an ad by a
company the companies say here's our
brand you want to Coca-Cola or whatever
right yeah but the thing is there's none
of those advertisers if those if those
advertisers don't want to be on Twitter
you can bet your [ __ ] ass they do not
want to be on true social all right
because right here what you have is they
are trying to
um sugarcoat are they trying to make it
appear that there's an ad because that's
what it is
technically an ad and they're pushing it
from truth social and they're saying
this is a sponsored truth
so [ __ ] dumb so the app is saying
this is a sponsored truth which is a
sponsored ad okay these are truth social
ads so some truth that you pay for oh my
God because here's the thing this is
this is one of those things when you're
like this ad reminds me of those like
hey man take these supplements and
you'll get a big [ __ ] muscle you're
gonna you know it'll do all of this [ __ ]
right Alex Jones or infowar stuff
exactly any supplement anything's like
you your dick your muscles your dish
your debt like whatever crazy should we
sell dick pills I don't know maybe we
should sell dick pills I mean I'm sure
you can buy them fake Gabe would
probably buy our big deals he's like oh
my God
but what we'd have to do is Trick him
into it we'd have to be like no it
actually makes your dick smaller and
you'd be like oh Tony and Gabe's Liars I
believe everything the opposite of what
they say right so let me buy those those
little dick pills that make my dick huge
it'll be huge
Gabe can let us know if he'll buy those
or not I I would I would probably
100 put money on the fact that they gave
would buy uh dick pills but but here's
the thing though here's the thing though
with this ad Gabe I can't figure out why
they went with skin tags like if they're
gonna because here's the reason it's the
same reason when you're trying to it's
it's cheap it is these these products
are not FDA approved do you think he's
doing the whole Infowars things with
true social here I think they think
that's because I think it's those things
that you it's it's the products you find
in a gas station where it's like the
horny goat weed these are like what
horny goat weed horny goat weed you
never heard of that horny goat weed no
what is it I'm now interested I
definitely think big Gabe would buy that
oh one I bet you when you go into it you
go in a gas station yeah I don't know if
they still sell them at one point does
anyone go into a gas station anymore I
mean if you don't buy cigarettes or like
sometimes I have to go in when my credit
card they're like oh go see the cashier
I just keep cancel on the [ __ ]
until it takes my card yeah but those
pills are there's like these natural
supplements that are not FDA approved
like every other supplement they're not
FDA approved and they're literally like
oh man you want to [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
like it's supposed to be like some sort
of like natural Viagra do they say that
on the bottle do you want to [ __ ] well
they're sold in these little hornets and
they have them they have them behind the
glass they just like have them taped on
the glass does it look like weed
no no no no no no no
I was like horny oh it's like oh okay so
like it's not a bunch of supplements
inside the capsules exactly and the weed
the horny goat weed is inside the campus
so is it like because horny goat weed is
that like a technical name or is it like
a specific type look it up now yeah look
this [ __ ] up I mean I'm interested in
this because here we are looking at
Trump's socials Baron wart which is a
plant oh okay again
um which is just a it's a green plant
it's maximum strength it's got a [ __ ]
RAM on there so it literally does
nothing besides fool you into thinking
you're gonna get it yeah I mean like
you're gonna buy it it's the way it's
labeled is exotic herbal formula and the
way that they sell it is to be like oh
you want performance and energy for the
BET like that's how it's I almost bet on
some of these horny goat weed packages
like make America great again they're
like yeah oh probably oh I bet 100 they
lean into the hole and so this is
amazing these ads are they exactly these
ads are the same type of cheap products
you find in a gas station where some
[ __ ] bro comes incredible at two in
the morning says I want to buy that [ __ ]
or they go on to Infowars or they're
watching an infomercial none of this
[ __ ] is regulated so they buy it and the
reason that that truth social is able to
get these people is because it's cheap
advertisers and there's dumb [ __ ] like
fake Gabe who will click it and they get
paid for the click and they will most
likely check out that item on whatever
the thing is so I mean this is the other
thing that's the other thing that I was
really thinking here is that true social
knows Their audience and oh yeah
shitloaded skin tags like I was like
social 100 sure this is a bunch of old
[ __ ] that is definitely the
group of people who are in their house
at three in the morning right just
letting the infomercials like it hits 2
A.M you ever had a skin tag though no
you've never had one oh man it's a
mother they're irritating as [ __ ] I'm
irritating as [ __ ] no I mean I I can see
what they look like in this thing but
I've never had one myself right I've
never had I've luckily been able to go
to the dermatologist and never had
something like that removed
so you went to the dermatologist now I
have a dermatologist
is it because you're lighting there is
that
[Music]
[Laughter]
is it the tone okay so uh that's an
inside joke
um and and and if there's a hate Watcher
listening they'll know but here's the
thing about the skin tag thing honestly
though not that there's anything wrong
with him because I've had one or two and
they're irritating as [ __ ] they normally
happen like in your armpit or something
and they're they get pretty [ __ ]
irritating
um just because cut them off I don't
know what you do well I mean you there's
a lot of different things you can do you
can go to True social and they'll tell
you a lot about it you can read more
right here but um I mean the other thing
you can do is just go to Walgreens and
they've got you know they've got a place
where you can get the [ __ ] to you know
take them off now the the best way is
just get a [ __ ] band-aid and put it
because it's just dead skin that builds
up and it creates a tag because because
it's an area where it's rubbing right oh
gosh I don't know I don't know what you
should do really is go to True social
they've got all kinds of I'm sure
they'll educate you on yeah
and why you need to remove it right well
I mean it's not like dangerous or
anything I don't think right it just
it's irritating as [ __ ] I've always just
I always just take a Band-Aid and put it
over it yeah and I mean like this the
sticky part like you you just suffocate
that piece of skin and it'll eventually
like the skin will die right just like
when you put a Band-Aid and like your
skin turns really kind of gross if you
leave it on there for a long time it's
same thing you just leave it on there
and [ __ ] dies it'll fall right
off I look Dr Tony is here to help you
with your skin okay gotcha you don't
need to go to True social you just come
here get in the gym hey Tony what are we
supposed to do about the funniest thing
that I see about uh
this ad is there's no there's no company
there's no brand out here that's what I
that's what I wanted to ask you about
right right because I don't believe that
this is a company this is this literally
this is probably a deal that true social
has made with a white labeled a white
labeled supplement company like like um
because we found that out through the
Alex Jones trials he was using white
labeled
um
right where they would drop ship his
stuff with their with his label on it
right so they were bottling up all this
[ __ ] and they would just when they get
in order they just slap his label on it
and mail it to whatever dumb [ __ ]
ordered that [ __ ] this is probably the
exact same thing where true social is
putting these ads out because it's free
to advertise all your dumb [ __ ] users
that are in the thread and and then and
this maybe elon's new model I don't know
maybe he sends out Twitter
um supplements on how to get rid of skin
tags and moles I don't know but is it is
a dumb oh God I almost bet that's what
this is that's when I saw this I was
like holy [ __ ] this isn't Alex Jones
White labeled herbal supplement thing
because I don't remember I don't
remember seeing any ads on this platform
before and if you remember it Trump owes
millions of dollars to different vendors
which I mean she's like I don't know why
you'd ever go into business with him if
you know the his track record as a
business man
um but if you look at what's going on
like yeah you bring up you bring up um
Elon and we can talk about that in a
little in a second yeah well I I wanna I
wanna since we're talking about skin
tags
skin tag does he do how many War Room
shows does this guy do because this is
on Lindell TV so like does he do
different shows for different Traders I
mean I think honestly
or is it all in syndication
um I don't think what is the name of
this show though well this is war room
on Lindell TV but he has war room on um
the other [ __ ] Trader News Network
that that Charlie Kirk's on the um the
real America's Voice or whatever the
[ __ ] it is yeah so maybe maybe it's uh
so he's he's like double dipping here
yeah it's possible I don't know I might
be that horny goat we'd keep it I rarely
watch uh
I rarely watch Lindell TV yeah I mean I
catch it every once in a while you know
so when they've got something really
good on right yeah like when he's
freaking out about getting his phone
taken by the FBI at a Hardee's yeah you
gotta watch that uh when I look up the
when I look up
Steve Bannon War Room Battleground right
is what it's called in oh so it's a
different so it's a different show with
a different name yeah because because uh
bannon's show on real America's voice is
called War Room pandemic right so it's
called so I guess he's he's franchised
this out in a way to like have or or
made different stuff seems like he's
preparing to need some money or
something now the guy sitting in the
frame next to him is uh Jack uh prostate
oh yeah yeah
did he okay well he's a snowflake too
you're gonna find that out in this clip
um
he's the pizza gay guy that's what he's
famous for is he drove the the gang went
with the gun another weirdo who was
obsessed with children right underage
children and photos of children right
[ __ ] these people are [ __ ] crazy man
people they're [ __ ] crazy people who
post photos of underage children you
know is minors groups they've been doing
it too being gross they went and they
stole [ __ ] from my my wife's personal
Facebook page and we're posting pictures
of my children these people are weirdos
they're [ __ ] weirdos and it really is
pervy and it borderlines on pedophilia
if you want to know the honest truth but
here is here is um the human skin tank
Steve Bannon and Jack prostate on the
pizzagate guy discussing why this
election and what we should do about it
well I've got to ask you don't take this
the wrong way because I know you're a
son of uh Pennsylvania what in the hell
is wrong with that state and what I mean
you don't have a governor and you don't
have you don't have as a senator it
don't blame the left don't blame
fetterman you know the cyborg blame the
Republican establishment particularly
the business Community what is the
problem with the Commonwealth sir
okay so Steve Bannon there not asking a
question but really steering it to hey
it's the Republican's fault did you
notice how they're they're they're in in
this mindset that they're going to uh
fight the people in their own party like
he's like [ __ ] the Democrats [ __ ] the
Liberals it's all about killing the
Republicans and oh yeah they're the
infighting I don't know what's going to
happen in terms of this implosion of
what the aftermath is going to be but
I'm going to tell you right now that
they're setting up for a wasteland which
is right now you've got uh Raby MC
forehead I mean five had uh Matt Gates
who again another [ __ ] weird
pedophile what's his name what's his
name again Raven MC5 head rapey MC5 head
yeah oh okay I mean I don't know I'm
just saying like if you're hanging out
with uh Roger Stone and Joel Greenberg
and right you've been paying for
underage girls to have sex with and
sending payments on venmo and cash app
they're in the same category as these
people posting pictures of other
people's children it's the same pervy
weird ass perverted [ __ ] now let's
listen to here what pizzagate guy's
response is to to Steve Bannon
it's I mean it's on brand listen
Steve let me explain what's going on in
Pennsylvania you saw this in Michigan as
well but really really strongly in
Pennsylvania
we've gone away
from an election day we've gone away
from an election uh 72 hours they've
turned it into an election season but
here's the problem
Republicans were asleep at the wheel of
on this
so voting that's the problem with voting
the reason why the reason why
Republicans lose Gabe is because of
voting this is really stupid bonus they
lose when people actually support
democracy when they when they do the
thing that this country was founded on
when they actually exercised their right
to vote and say hey I have a voice and I
want to use that voice to vote for this
candidate or vote for this person or
this policy referendum or Amendment
whatever it might be
that is something
that they don't like and they really
don't like it when there's a group of
people because you got to remember
whenever there is a voter demographic
that confronts the Republican Party
Latino black community uh young voters
women any of these people from those
demographics you know uh non-white lgbtq
like any of these people that say ah
your policies are pretty [ __ ] up and
you don't actually acknowledge me as a
person or a whole person you look at me
as a monolith or you look at me as a
political Pawn or you look at me as
someone you can control
those people that confront the
Republican party and say ah you know
what not today [ __ ] Satan that is the
group that they hate and Jack here Jack
prostate the the
the the Meltdown yes the Meltdown that
they had on there
I'm gonna show this video Angela says on
on YouTube she says I loved watching
Charlie Kirk melt down last night I'm
gonna show that video with him and Jack
and everyone and everyone is melting
down and they're trying to blame someone
and and right now what they're realizing
is that they either blame the Young
Generation or they have to blame people
within their own party who weren't
fascist enough because that's what
people like uh Matt Gates is doing he's
blaming Mitch McConnell Ronald McDaniel
and also
um uh uh Kevin McCarthy because they
weren't fascist enough they weren't
America first they were America's second
they were the one America the first
Nazis they were like ah maybe you know
we'll do some things but maybe we
shouldn't do all of those crazy things
and Matt Gates and and Lauren bobert and
Margaret Taylor green and Ron DeSantis
and all these other [ __ ] fascist
[ __ ] want to go and take these rights
away from people and because these
people in The Establishment didn't go
far enough they're now saying you gotta
go and what's happening is you're seeing
the infighting take place in real time
online in front of everyone to see it
started happening that night on Election
night and Tuesday it went into Fox News
on Wednesday and it's going gonna happen
again today I'm going to show some Jesse
Waters Clips Jesse Waters actually lost
his sense of it
what they've realized is they are
unwilling to look at themselves in the
in their mirror and see that they are
the problem you know it's like that that
clip where it's uh or that that sketch
where it's like the Nazis like a Visa
are we the badges are we are we the
problem are we the bad guys you're the
bad that's literally what's going on
right now what you you tweeted at um or
I think you grabbed his uh yeah I'm not
I'm not gonna float tweet that
[ __ ] you said uh oh the
Republican party is fighting what a
shame and here's Matt Gantz um tweet
here would you call him rapey mcwhat
rapey MC5 head Raby MC5 heads tweet here
says um McCarthy McConnell McDaniel
mcphail yeah which really honestly like
the people that are gonna survive this I
and I I'll I'm just being
straightforward the people that are
going to survive this infighting are
McCarthy Connell and McDaniel we are not
going to get rid of Kevin McCarthy Mitch
McConnell or Rona McDaniel they are
going to survive this those are the ones
that are going to survive this and and
anyone who's not on their side is going
to be the mick failure here right and we
see it we see it with our title today um
everyone I don't know if everyone
noticed the New York Post
um they're it was a trumpety Dumpty is
that was the Trump quality it was the
New York Post uh um basically destroying
the Republican Party can they yeah here
it is so if no one knows New York Post
is actually owned by uh what's that
guy's name that owns Fox News uh talk to
them I am um
Murdoch Murdock right he's the reason
why we're in the situation that we're in
in the first ways yeah but here is the
uh wait you're telling wait hold on
you're telling me that the guy who
controls the media and Fox News and
other Publications
uh created someone and then now is upset
that that person
[ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah they're they're pissed
off oh got it okay but here's here's the
words on it here's what they printed
which is they they really don't know how
to do design at all this is horrible Don
who couldn't build a wall had a great
fall can all the gop's men put put the
party back together again no and then
they caught trumpy Dumpty this is this
is the rag that basically made Donald
Trump right like this is it
um other than the National Enquirer
which is another egg to help make Donald
Trump but but they're turning on him big
time but here is I want to show you
because this is this guy's a nobody that
I'm about to show you this is a video of
just some random Rando Trump supporter
in Illinois apparently
um now these are long videos but I'm
telling you
that this is seeping deep inside their
minds like they are mind [ __ ] here and
they've been mind [ __ ] by all the lies
and it is showing hard on social media
with these [ __ ] idiots
um just watch this this guy right here
you dumb [ __ ] in Michigan who
voted for Gretchen Whitmer
you basically made it so that parents
because you voted for prop three
you made it so that parents have no
control over their kids gender
okay prop 3 in Michigan was the was the
proposition that um
that Michigan's michiganders voted
um in in favor to make sure to preserve
bodily autonomy for women that's what
that bill was about way way it's not
about mutilating children Tony no their
minds can't focus on anything this is
what I'm telling you about these Matt
Walsh Ben Shapiro the the Charlie Kirk
these [ __ ] freaks these weirdos are
absolutely obsessed and cannot stop
thinking about children's genitalia so
much so that they're so easily duped
that a proposition in Michigan this guy
does not live in Michigan he lives in
Illinois I think he goes on to say that
but in Michigan which is an easy easy
search it's not hard you can even find
the official language of the [ __ ]
proposition easily you just gotta type
it in and you can find not just the
ballot language but the entirety of the
language I will say fake Gabe is
probably going to have a little bit of a
hard time searching for that
um if you need a tutorial man uh you
know we can make a video or something
yeah he might I bet make games or
someone can give him yeah they're gonna
chop off they're gonna chop off little
boys wieners that's what mission that's
what that bill in Michigan said and the
bill in Michigan all it does is make
sure to secure and codify that women in
Michigan have the right to their privacy
in a doctor's office when it comes to
their pregnancy that is what the [ __ ]
thing does right
um but this guy doesn't understand it
and the reason why is because he's
listening to the Jack prostates the
pizzagate guy the Charlie Kirks the Ben
Shapiro's the Matt Walsh's but let's
continue here with this guy's delusion
that their teacher can tell them oh you
you want to be a girl you can be one
they can influence them to change their
gender
this is this is what you voted for
not even close yeah like not even close
and this is this is why
um
I linked it I linked it also in the chat
so yeah so literally from the house
right Michigan Government right website
the actual like the whole language of
the bill you can go read it says nothing
about teachers telling people they can
they're not forcing anyone to do
anything about their gender it's a
reproductive freedom for all repetition
right it's it's not asking but they they
hear reproductive and they're like
gender wieners right children and they
get all confused right like they there's
like the literal is adds the right to
abortion and concerts
abortion in contraceptive use to the
state constitution right men's it amends
the Michigan Constitution to add the
right to choose to have an abortion and
use contraceptives allows the state
regulation uh of abortion after the
point of fetal viability this is
protecting the life of the mother in
case the child uh is life puts the
mother risk or dies and you know again
puts the mother's life at risk this
allows them to say hey this is my body
this is my choice it's their Republicans
Republicans said
when they overturned Roe v Wade they
said okay the decision should be back to
the states right all the states said all
right nope that's not what they no they
they didn't mean that they didn't
actually mean that let's continue with
this [ __ ] here
because you're robotic and you have to
mark the blue check box oh my God but
you voted for a woke [ __ ]
we did it here
in Illinois too
doesn't it look like he's been crying
for days like yeah literally like the
car is steamed up he's you know he's got
to put the vents on you know like this
is one of those things this guy is so
triggered by another state oh letting
women
protect their own bodies the boaters
going and voting for it this just they
don't believe in democracy they don't
believe in it they really don't they
overturned Roe v Wade and the whole
thing was States rats so it's not so
it's not States right now that's what
you're saying so what is it they hate
women they [ __ ] hate women I I I I
can prove it I can prove it I believe I
believe that this guy in the thread
um Let me show let me just the next one
uh
I believe he said something about it in
this one uh let's see oh there we go
here's the here's the hand handmade
Viking here handmade Tales Viking let's
let's listen
it really does look like he's been
crying though right like I haven't even
started yeah you started talking I mean
dude
he's been bawling like like in a fetal
position crying yeah
window looks super steamed up
it's November it's fall you know winter
weather it's cold outside
this is one of the guys driving around
the country peeing peeing in buckets and
taking showers at the gym going to the
Trump rally side yeah yeah probably he's
probably got a bug that's in the trunk
he buys a bunch of Like Home Depot
buckets
put it in there he's like you know the
best kind of stuff is my own P he's like
the guy from [ __ ] and [ __ ] uh
dodgeball he's like I drink my own urine
because I like the taste you know I'm
like yeah well let's let's listen to the
uh the wrench Dodger here from Dodgeball
I don't know why
I don't either man we voted for that
fool in Illinois yeah
I didn't vote for him oh my God Aaron
Bailey
he's rubbing his eyes I did what I could
I did my duty as a citizen there you go
dude that's all you need that's the
video everyone else did the same they
have [ __ ] they have the right to vote
and they exercised that right and they
said hey I want to choose this and you
can't get mad at that person for
choosing what they chose right well
listen to what he says vote listen to
what he says here I think this is the
part where he goes on about women
but we have too many abortionists in
this territory and too many
leftists that's just just vote blue no
matter what they can't see any other
things so they're robotic about it just
like we are you know the red we I voted
all red I even kicked the judges out I
I he doesn't get it now listen to what
he says because he goes on he goes on to
start dunking on Trump here listen to
what he says about DeSantis and Trump
where are these people's mindset because
they're really super confused not only
are they confused about about feelings
that they get when they see like
pictures of wieners and then they get
confused about bathrooms and who's going
in what bathroom who's sitting in the
stall next to them like they get all
kinds of confused they get confused
about the Santos and Trump and we should
take advantage of that like we should
really wedge hard on that with our
narrative but listen I'm just telling
you people
that
I'm sorry for Michigan and I'm sorry for
New York and I'm sorry for Illinois and
I'm sorry for California you did it to
us
you're stuck with the worst governors in
the existence of the of the world like
Amber history Whitmer
pritzker Newsome and hokel these people
are horrible yeah horrible
bad for the country in every way just
like Biden is yeah exactly
I don't know what's wrong with the left
it it really is it's crazy he's like
these Governors are as bad as Biden and
the country's like well you know what
they must not be that bad like literally
he's he's they run straight into the
point straight into also I'm going to
tell you someone who lives in California
no Newsome did he's done a pretty good
job when it came to handling the
pandemic making sure that we had a
surplus making sure that people were
paid an additional amount on top of the
Unemployment uh you know this is a guy
that actually takes stuff seriously made
sure that we actually uh added
um you know women's rights in a bodily
autonomy in you know it's about and
enshrined in our state's Constitution he
made sure to uh combat the same type of
[ __ ] Bounty laws in in Texas except
to do the same thing for gun
manufacturers that is something that
I've I have not seen one single other
Republican
or lawmaker put something into action
that actually would combat the rise of
of of mass shootings by putting blame on
the people who make them and not doing
their actual duty to identify there's a
public uh there there's a there there's
a issue there's a problem right now that
is affecting our public and the safety a
health concern
and they don't want to do that but
people like this guy who say
hey they voted blue no matter what you
know they're like a robot they picked it
okay great whatever you you can have
your own opinion on stuff that's great
the same way you can have your own
opinion on who to vote for so you can't
get pissed off that somebody voted for
somebody right like whether that's the
right or wrong choice it's your opinion
your opinion again your body your vote
you can vote however you want you can
cry in your car because the people
weren't voted in or the or certain
things were were passed or whatever you
hate women whatever it might be my dude
you gotta [ __ ] stop crying take the L
and move on yeah
[ __ ] cope well it even like if you see
at the top here it says at least we will
get back the house like even his Co even
his [ __ ] knowledge of how this is
gonna work and how this is gonna go is
lacking because he doesn't know that
even if you take back the house man it's
it's gonna be like one or two votes
you're not gonna get the [ __ ] you want
other than your stupid theatric
um investigations which are going to
come up with nothing I want to point out
and you know I I also bet this guy was
[ __ ] cheering on those guys who try
to kidnap Whitmer I guarantee it this
guy was like oh yeah she [ __ ] deserve
it probably he probably thinks they got
their raw end of the deal by actually
being convicted I mean you want to point
out something one of those people I want
to point out some here Wanda on Facebook
here says Republicans don't hate Trump
she's talking about our title
Republicans hate Trump which they do she
says Trump 2024 you're only proving
you're only proving our point about you
being [ __ ] robotic [ __ ] delusional
cultist I'm not talking about cultist
Wanda I'm talking about Republicans
that's what I'm saying you're a cultist
you're not a republican you are deluded
like we're in a situation now that we
with this election we clearly know now
that Maga is cultist and people are
going to vote against manga even
Republicans in States like Kentucky that
vote against your manga stupid [ __ ] like
taking away women's bodily autonomy like
this guy's talking about let's get to
the part and then I want to move on to
the pizza gate Charlie Kirk video
because that's a great one let's let's
watch him cry about Trump and DeSantis
here this is great they care more about
what's in between their legs than their
pocketbook there again the genitalia
thing the same account doesn't matter
the fact that they go to the gas station
and it costs them 150 bucks to fill up
their SUV that doesn't hurt their feet
rights are more important than gas
prices along with their lives also why
are you using the extreme not everyone
has a [ __ ] SUV Ron DeSantis did a
great job here it is you know in Florida
he then moved
he's probably the best thing that the
Republicans have at this point that's
pathetic I love Donald Donald Trump but
here it is he needs to look at this
election and understand
his they hate him so much that they'll
come out in droves to stop him
and I never want to give up on Donald
Trump I don't want to do it but
maybe they're ready to cry oh my God we
gotta wrap our arms around Ron DeSantis
at this point because oh my God what a
[ __ ] cuck this is hilarious because
this idea that we hate Trump more than
we hate DeSantis you people are [ __ ]
dumb we are gonna go we are gonna get
out into Rose and [ __ ] bury Ron
DeSantis under mountains of votes once
he leaves the State of Florida if he
leaves in a race that we get to vote in
from the state of Florida we are going
to bury that [ __ ] in votes you
stupid bastards it has nothing to do
with which fascist you pick how didn't
we prove that to you in this election
you bone-headed [ __ ] we proved
that to you it doesn't matter which one
we're gonna come and we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna let democracy have its
way with you because you got to remember
if anyone watched the uh the victory on
you know speech that he did that night
he goes is you know Florida's where woke
goes to die like what the [ __ ] man like
have you looked at the definition of
woke which is like you know being alert
to an injustice in society saying hey
that's not right you know there's racism
obviously Ron DeSantis doesn't feel like
there's any racism because all lives
matter according to him and all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] but when you say where
woke goes to die you've pretty much
alienated the voter block that says yeah
you know what like being woke is not bad
being woke is not some stigma or like
some
taboo thing being woke is just being
alert to injustices in society saying oh
yeah there's a problem we should fix
that oh hey people don't have access to
this we should work on that oh maybe we
shouldn't use people as political pawns
and fly them to Martha's Vineyard that's
not so good that's not being woke that's
just that or that there's no issue with
being woke rather right and I would hope
that as we as a society progress forward
that we identify hey all the things that
we thought were cool to do or great to
do we shouldn't do any more I mean like
you look at our own history and that's
why you look at uh other Republicans who
say we don't want to put slavery in our
history books or anything that we did
with indigenous people in this in the
colonizers
um you know even there were two measures
also that I just saw I did not know this
was on there but I saw last night two
measures that were in two different
states about slavery yep
um I believe Maryland yeah and I I think
it was Tennessee or Kentucky finally
banned slavery which is like what the
[ __ ] right well I I I well here's the
mighty librarian puts it very well here
I'd vote for a ham sandwich over a Maga
candidate it doesn't matter which and I
don't even like ham that much I mean
really I mean I'm I'm down for turkey
sandwiches yeah turkey's great like I
mean like I'll throw Ham's not right I
feel like ham ham by itself it's not
really my thing but if you throw ham in
with some like turkey or salami or
something like that you know what I
would tell you what you know what I
would eat like a tortilla with Slim Jims
and then cheese whiz on top of it I
probably would just go crazy over there
but but but
aside from that my the mighty librarian
makes a really good point here it
doesn't [ __ ] matter who they put up
and I mean Democrats like it does not
matter at this point if you're going to
choose between whatever the Democrats
put up in a [ __ ] fascist you're gonna
take whatever the Democrats put up and
it is proven now that that is our goal
is for democracy right like that yeah
and the other thing I want to point out
about librarian
um Librarians I don't know if anyone
knows this Librarians are are going to
single-handedly take Donald Trump down
with Nara in these documents we're gonna
we're gonna get more to that story
probably in the coming weeks this
election and have some residual effects
but I just want to putting that out
since mining Librarians in the chat
there
um speaking of ham sandwiches
um here are some this is a lifeless this
is really weird
Steve Bannon looks really weird in this
doesn't he it's because he's on a TV
kind of thing it's he's there I mean you
get I mean like you've got a bunch of in
cells with the leader in cell the skin
tag himself Steve Bannon with uh I like
boys uh little kids pedophile You Know
Jack prostate you've got my forehead is
just shy of rapey mc4 five heads uh face
do you think they're in a competition
like they're having like surgery on
their forehead though Charlie Kirk's
face his lip comes up which more gum
show and his face gets bigger and his
hairline recedes so there's that one
cartoon that people keep using for
Charlie Kirk and they're like here's
Charlie Kirk in a cartoon fashion and it
literally looks like him where he's like
it does face is blue his face is small
like his eyes his mouth his nose are
small but the face has like ballooned
out almost like you draw uh uh like you
know when you're a kid and you took your
Peas on your plate and you like make a
drawing of a face it's almost like you
make a drawing in the face in the middle
of the of the dinner bro right and she's
like all empty right it's all empty with
just the face and the small face in the
middle so who else is in this
um because I think this guy over here in
this hat over here isn't that Benny
Johnson or is this guy I don't know
which one are any of these Benny Johnson
maybe it's not I don't know I don't
think I don't know I don't know who
these other two picks but this guy on
the left I've seen the clipboard this
guy I don't know if it's this clip yeah
the guy on the left here I don't know if
it's this clip or a different one but
this is him realizing uh
that certain there was a race that had
already been called well this one really
what gets me here is
um and I'm going to explain here in a
minute what what the problem with these
fragile white males are and you see that
they're all white men in this Frame
um I'll tell you what the problem with
them is afterwards about what they're
terrified of and really it's a
deep-seated fear that they have that
drives this entire [ __ ] narrative but
let's listen to this clip it's not too
long but and this is going to be Trump's
longest lasting Legacy I hope he gets
another term I hope all that happens but
honestly you know Donald Trump igniting
the same way Reagan did an 80 just
changing and getting young people
ideological in the ranks in the trenches
Steve I mean this is how you long term
you change the movement Jack you see it
firsthand every day
so literally Charlie Kirk is saying the
opposite of what is reality which is not
surprising like he's like stands for
them this is a huge movement now this is
how you activate a movement like what
are you talking like if anything the
results should tell the Republican party
they should have dumped Trump two years
ago they should not even let him be the
nominee while he was being president
like they should they should have ran
someone and beat him then like that's
what you should have done and you're not
even aware of that even after three
elections that he has lost for you but
let's see what what the pizzagate guy
has to say about
what he thinks is reality listen to what
he leans into this is weird look you do
see this and Charlie
when you go out to the schools you see
it and you go when people come up to us
at events there is a real energy and
that people realize there's a movement
here that goes beyond any one election
go that it's a tectonic plate shift
because the other side I want to say
this
you saw how unmarried women went for the
left in droves something 37 points the
68 win okay the left literally wants to
turn everyone into an unmarried woman
literally
literally and you know what I mean by
that that's what they want to do because
that's how they win so that shame that
regret that bitterness that anger that's
just kind of there the super
pro-abortion vote that's what they want
to maximize throughout the country I'm
not saying online but by the way I'm
gonna get a lot of hate for this
um
okay so here's the thing
first off
these guys wonder why women don't
like them I'm not wait this is the
reason oh okay okay so they had an app
what the [ __ ] was this app called that
they released oh no right stuff right
and no one got on it this is the reason
why well no no no no no that's not true
not that true there were people on the
right stuff which is an app that's
created by the sister of Kaylee
mcinerney which is backed by Peter Thiel
another uh huge mega Republican donor uh
big in the tech space was one of the
First Investors into Facebook just so
people know who that is right uh buddy
buddy with Elon Musk he he basically
delivered as JD Vance in Ohio yes yes
and so uh uh Kaylee mcenany sister
started a company called The Right Stuff
the right stuff is a dating app that you
know you swipe right on your match you
know [ __ ] some dumb innuendo on
swiping
um and what ended up happening was
people joined not a lot of people joined
but people joined
and some women joined some men joined uh
but the women didn't really care for it
too much the women I wonder what could
the women jump ship deleted the app and
didn't come back because what they
realized it was a [ __ ] sausage fest
they walked into a room with a bunch of
dudes it's like when you get to a party
and I can't relate because I'm I'm not a
woman I haven't dealt with this type of
harassment before but I can imagine that
if you're a woman and you go to a party
you go to a club or a bar or something
and all guys look it's like oh there's
that woman that comes in a bar or
whatever this venue is and they're all
like hey what's up what's up what's up
what's up let me buy you a drink what's
your name what's your name can I get you
this can I get you that what's up let me
get your number let me take you home let
me do this all of you got a boyfriend
where's your man what you got you got a
hair on that finger crazy absurd
harassment that you get when you go out
to these places
these are all just a bunch of [ __ ] in
cells that live with their parents that
are paying for those drinks because they
still have an allowance or because their
mom gave them 20 bucks for a slice of
pizza and a beer or whatever the [ __ ]
they've got easy on the pizza you're
gonna piss jack off I'm just saying but
what I will say also is that these are
the types of guys that you find those
places so the app literally shifted to
become a an accurate representation of
Mega Men out there in the dating scene
and it's just a bunch of single dudes
waiting
for the woman that they can just oppress
by saying you don't have the right to
vote you're gonna have to have my baby
you can't go to work you have to stay in
the kitchen make me a sandwich all of
that [ __ ] and they got upset and they
and the women were like [ __ ] this noise
they left and all the dudes were like oh
dude what's going on look look you know
and so now it's just a bunch of dudes in
the app nobody could have seen that
coming
do you want me to tell you what the what
the real deep-seated problem here is
with these guys
uh insecurity well I mean that's kind of
obvious uh lack of confidence here's
here's the deal a fear of their own uh
non-masculinity being shown to the world
that that is true well they'll be
Hotline in public
there's a shown to be a fraud or there's
there's a long there's a long list
there's a lot
but here's here's the thing that drives
this more than anything else
you know you were talking about them
going in a bar and hitting on a woman
right
Jack here is terrified that he will go
in a bar he will hit on a beautiful
women that he will want to have sex with
and that is why he's hitting on her not
her personality not what she's drinking
not any kind of connection just simply
he wants to have sex with her
that and he hits on her and she goes
home with him okay are you following the
story so far this is a an a a thing that
plays out in their brain all the time
goes home
with her and and this is why he's he's
saying what he's saying
and when he gets her home and they start
to do the the dirty you know because
it's been a long time since Jack's
probably ever had his you know thing
touched besides himself right
and then he discovers a penis
and that not his on the other person
that is what they're terrified of that
they'll like it they are terrified this
is the same Nick Fuentes watching
transporn type thing that they caught
him watching drains this is the same
fear that they have they have this
innate fear
that somehow they're going to be tricked
into liking weiner like this is the
thing that they're terrified of well
they're afraid it's really afraid of
this this is why they say these things
like he was he was saying you know the
line that they have chicks with dicks
like that's the stupid Trope right and
that's what he was trying to say when
he's like they're trying to make all
people unmarried women you know what I
mean you know what I mean you know what
I mean Charlie you pick that one girl up
you know what I'm saying I did it too
you know I don't wanna and then and then
I had to you know I had to like it
they are obsessed obsessed obsessed with
other people's genitalia obsessed with
it like like the guy with the red beer
we were watching couldn't focus on
anything but other people's [ __ ] [ __ ]
in their pants this guy can't do
anything else pizzagate guy can't do
anything else he literally has to say
out loud the reason why the left is
winning and the reason why they're gonna
win is because they're trying to turn
all men into women
and that we're at risk we're at risk for
fragile white men if we don't know who's
a man and who's a woman because what's a
woman this is this this is this nonsense
not forbid you you know you feel a
certain way and find someone attractive
and you're drawn to them and say hey
look there's a lot more to this person
that I didn't realize and I actually do
like them regardless of whatever body
parts they have or way they they
identify that's what they are definitely
afraid that they're gonna you know
they're gonna get a surprise like oh
[ __ ] I am attracted to you but then
there's this and everything that I've
been taught before this and I've said to
people online would contradict
completely how I feel right now and I'm
totally insecure and I can't actually be
comfortable my own body that is Charlie
K Charlie Kirk that is Jack prostate
that's [ __ ] Steve Bannon that's
Donald Trump that's Donald Trump Jr
that's Ron DeSantis that's all of these
people who have these insecurities and
they are afraid they are afraid to be
comfortable in their own body and they
are intimidated by other people who are
I sent you a video um the other day on
Instagram that
uh hang on let me she
um you remember this comedian she um she
had a I think a beer thrown at her at a
comedy club oh yeah
toss Ariel Ariel yeah um here is um this
is a great video let me see if I can do
yes
I hate Instagram with this thing okay
let's let's do this okay
I gotta redo this thing here it just
doesn't work like [ __ ] Twitter does
where I can pause the video here we go
all right let's listen and my honest
answer was yes absolutely which he was
surprised by so I explained to him well
for one he's more than just a body to me
right he's a human being I love him for
who he is divorce is expensive but two
but two and more importantly
my least favorite thing about him
[Laughter]
and just so everyone knows I don't know
if you missed the front of it but she's
talking about a hypothetical where her
husband asked her if I decided to become
trans and transition to a woman would
you still be with me like would you and
obviously she's suggesting here that the
worst thing about him is that he's a man
but listen it gets even better
he's a man
right he has a lot of he has a lot of
wonderful qualities that's not one of
them
uh he asked me if I would stay with him
she's hilarious by the way this is the
one that had the uh it was a beer right
it was a beer can and then she yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she had a beer
and and then picked it up that's what I
thought I sent that to you I'm like ah
that that rings a bell when you're
talking about it it's uh I mean you know
it's funny in terms of like it's true
right well they really do they really do
not have any clue what's going on like
they have no clue and they walk they
walk straight into the point like uh
Little Marco he won he won his race like
he should be running Victory laps right
now but listen to what he says on Fox
news but I think we also have to
understand something I mean literally
every everything in our society and
culture is aligned against Republicans
it's America where Republicans went
anywhere every virtually every major
television and media Outlet in America
is against us all the celebrities all
the movie uh actors I mean you name it
it's just
we all hate you that's and it's not you
in general it's what you said in the
front part is that you are not up to
date like you have not you have not
uploaded and updated yourself to the new
software and what I mean by that is
you're just not caught up to 2022.
you're still stuck in 1950s Style
bigotry and you you really need to run
the update and to come to terms with
that your beliefs that you have are
outdated bigoted and people are not
gonna put up with them like we're just
not and we're gonna vote against you
accordingly so one or two ways Marco and
now he won in Florida because Florida's
a [ __ ] hellscape but here's the thing
and and there's a lot of different
reasons why Florida's a hellscape but
here's the thing and we can break that
down on a whole show another day but
here's the thing is that Margo here is
really he won he he won handily which is
crazy because the dude didn't even show
up
but he's so upset that Republicans lost
nationally yeah
because he knows what it means he knows
that eventually Florida can't stay this
red and and that's the thing folks is
that Texas can't stay this red Florida
can't stay this red Tennessee Kentucky
Alabama they're not going to stay this
red it's just not feasible because more
and more people are going to tell them
no you are not going to govern that way
that is what we as a democracy that's
what we the people we the voters get to
choose is who governs us and if you keep
doing a really stupid shitty job at
governing the people you are not going
to win elections that is and and it's
not a red or blue thing it really isn't
it's more of a hey
you suck at this and we don't want
people who suck at this to do this
because we want policies that reflect
the majority of people in this country
we're not divided folks we are not
divided there is a small percentage of
people in this country it's a large
number of people but a small percentage
that believe this garbage and they're
concentrated in these areas and they
will continue to look like they have
control in these areas and they will
continue to have some sort of minority
rule until we get in a place where we
will totally reject them all together
and I think we're gonna get there
eventually and there's still going to be
outliers but they're not going to be in
charge of anything they're not going to
be in charge of anything I mean the more
the more that the Republican Party puts
in their you know election uh cheat
toolbox which right now it is
gerrymandering you know redistricting it
is voter suppression it is voter
intimidation uh obviously this last
round uh involved election denialism
which
because of gen Z and because of women
and other people you know they said now
[ __ ] this there was truth and uh Trump
did lose the 2020 election and also
people you know preemptively like Katie
uh like uh uh Carey Lake
in Arizona in other places casting doubt
on you know Christina Bob casting doubt
on when results would come in and if
they came in too late it'd be kind of
shady and suspicious which is exactly
what Jack prostate was doing all of
these people trying to cast it out to
create this red Mirage you know and be
like oh well we're supposed to win all
the election polls said we're supposed
to win uh we didn't or we didn't have
this Red Wave like they thought and so
they are intentionally using those tools
so not only do you have intimidation
suppression gerrymandering uh you know
um election denialism which is just
election lying let's call what it is and
also now this new crazy attempt to
repeal the 26th amendment the Republican
party they cannot win without cheating
and people need to realize that they
have these tactics and if again if they
really did believe in a fair and safe
election or a fair and free and safe
election whatever however you want to
phrase it they wouldn't try so hard to
suppress your vote it doesn't make any
sense why would they take away your
right to vote
if they really believed in a free and
fair election
you know
well here's another little snowflake
and that has something to say about
unmarried women
um and I'm sure I'm sure the unmarried
women out there will definitely take
Jesse Waters advice on this I'm sure
they will but you see this also there's
nothing wrong with unmarried women so
the fact that Fox News and Republicans
the right wing are attacking unmarried
women they can go [ __ ] themselves
because guess what they chose to do what
they wanted to do which is they said you
know what I don't want to get married
isn't that the point why they're so
pissed off at unmarried women yeah
because they have the choice not to be
married and they chose that well it
makes them infused specifically though
it's that they chose not to be married
to them right that's to them right
they're they're butt hurt because this
woman
independent strong decided on her own to
say yeah [ __ ] it you know what I don't
need a man I can date around I cannot
date I can do whatever I want I can
raise a kid by myself a single parent
there's a lot of unmarried women that
have been with the same dude for a long
time and have children with that person
they just Goldie Hawn Kurt Russell
they're unmarried aren't they unmarried
I'm pretty sure I don't know but let's
listen let's listen to Jesse here and
let's see if the unmarried women in the
chat would take his advice
I doubt they do but let's let's listen
also single women are breaking for
Democrats by 30 points
and this makes sense when you think
about how Democrat policies are designed
to keep women single
but once women get married they vote
Republican married women married men go
for Republicans by double digits but
single women and voters under 40 have
been captured by democrats
so we need these ladies to get married
and it's time to fall in love and just
settle down guys go put a ring on it he
really believes that if if someone got
married then they'd be a republican this
is re this is yeah like he's like if if
a woman married me I'd make a republican
there's no way I'd let her do anything
but I'd slap her around if I had to like
this is the really this is dumb stupid
[ __ ] it's Jesse Waters needs I mean
honestly honestly he he has one of the
most punchable faces and I I really
would hate to I I mean I would hate to
have to play a video of him getting his
teeth kicked in but this is really
stupid [ __ ] when he says unmarried women
are single because that's just not true
either right that's the thing that they
that this guy this [ __ ] little incel
does not understand is that unmarried
women that doesn't mean they're single
you dumb [ __ ] yeah there are so
many people that decide to stay
unmarried that aren't single I've got
I've got multiple friends who have kids
and they're like why don't we get
married right yeah they're like you know
we don't get me like they're like we
don't need to do it like we know who we
are and we love each other and we we
don't need to be married right
it's it's crazy it's so dumb like
whether you want to get married or don't
get married guess what that's that
person's choice you can't decide and
just because Jesse Waters wants to make
sure that all of the women get [ __ ]
uh hitched to some random incel cuck you
know that that's his problem you know
clearly
clearly Jesse Waters is speaking from
his own insecurity or his own past or
whatever it might be and he's trying to
project that onto other people to say
the cure to make sure that we get more
Republican votes is to Hitch those women
and marry him throw a ring on it dudes
well here's Kath Jesus oh she's married
she voted him here's crystal says single
mom power
um I I think I think they're really
underestimating the are overestimating
really the marital status of women being
pissed off at them like it ain't got
nothing to do with being married you
dumb son of a [ __ ] it has to do with
you want to take away women's rights in
general in general but if you look at
this um this graphic he has up on the
screen this is actually really telling
and he doesn't even get it that
unmarried women
68 went for Democrats in the exit poll
right
um voters 18 to 24 61
voters age 25 to 29 65 voters 30 to 39
54 now what this tells me this graphic
here tells me
is that they're [ __ ] like literally
gen Z is coming and they're going to
over 70 percent vote for liberals in
this country because they don't want
fascists Like Jesse Waters here in
charge and the older generation is going
to you know I mean it happens naturally
they're they're not going to live much
longer and this generation is going to
get this generational gap between voting
for democracy and voting for autocracy
the Gap is going to get larger and
larger and larger and that's really what
this story is and they don't even see it
they don't get that hey it's a you
problem man it's a you problem this
problem that you have that you guys are
bitching about about oh unmarried women
and and people are are genitalia and and
CRT and all this nonsense just pure
stupid [ __ ] nonsense is a you problem
right it is a you problem Republicans
also uh
kr2rwp one oh there you go that's a good
handle uh MTG divorce
good example another person that's in
the Republican Party look she's she's
single or will be single and she's
Republican so clearly her orange isn't
there orange Messiah isn't he didn't he
get divorced a couple times I think yeah
yeah he did yeah he raped his wife too
the ex-wife yeah there's all kinds of
stuff but clearly shows you that the
sanctity of marriage does not prove
as a as a cure right for voting
Republican well also Donald Trump is a
[ __ ] Democrat all before this time
too
yeah he was like spells with Hillary
Clinton yeah
no idea Golf and Tennis with [ __ ]
Bill Clinton won she used to eat lunch
with Chuck Schumer like every quarter
they don't even [ __ ] they don't even
[ __ ] mention that that he used to go
eat lunch like they would have a lunch
to wear Chuck Schumer would ask Donald
Trump for money and Chuck Schumer and
him would eat a lunch together for money
like or to you know to do the whole I'm
gonna pay and then you're gonna make me
you know
I mean look do what you want to do marry
who you want to marry don't get married
it doesn't [ __ ] matter and the more
that you honestly at this point I'm just
like nobody should get married uh based
on the logic of Republicans I'm like
yeah nobody should ever get married if
they believe that married people turn
into Republicans like it's like some
[ __ ] Cinderella story like at
midnight if you don't get married you're
going to turn back into a Democrat but
if you do then boom you'll be able to uh
you'll be able to save face and stay in
this perfect world that is Republican
it's like dude nobody [ __ ] likes you
man I normally don't like the New York
Post but I'm gonna put the art back up
because everyone that's our show thanks
for coming and remember bonehead of the
week we're gonna put the poll out so
don't forget to um go to Twitter while
it's still there while it's still alive
at Tony Michael's pod you can vote at
Tony Michael's pod also subscriber to
the YouTube channel you'll be able to
vote there this afternoon this evening
sometime when the boneheads of the week
reveal themselves which I'm sure we're
going to be able to come up with both
ends pretty quick at this point yeah
um so everybody tomorrow is Friday we
have bone end of the week in the second
hour I think we may I I'm not sure I
haven't confirmed this with her yet uh
Gabe but I want to float this out there
we probably will have Dr Rachel
bidikoffer on nice tomorrow sometime so
in that first hour I'm hoping I have Dr
Rachel bittickoffer to give us her
analysis of what happened on Tuesday
um very important she's been very busy
she wanted to come on the show today
um but it just she just gets so much
that she's doing yeah with these counts
still going and everything she is super
busy so hopefully we'll be able to get
her on tomorrow if not whatever sometime
on next week so you guys can
um listen to Dr Rachel bittick offers uh
her run lapse um Victory laps because I
know she will she was super excited I
was messaging her that night she felt
really good about the results she still
feels really good about the results so
um hopefully we'll have uh doc on
sometime tomorrow or next week so stick
stay tuned for that as we do every every
day every weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 9 Pacific here on
YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the mind is touch
Facebook page and our Facebook page
same time same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon